hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich habe heute ein ganz
einfaches rezept für euch denn ich mache
heute einen obskuren und jetzt können
wir diesen tag entweder aus einem ganz
normaler rührteig machen mit butter oder
margarine oder eben mit öl und ich finde
die teige mit öl sind einfach etwas
lockerer und saftiger und deswegen nehme
ich hier ganz normal diesen öl teig den
ich immer mache und ich habe meine form
die hat so etwa ich glaube 28 zentimeter
im durchmesser
das ist eine obskuren form die am rand
eben schön gewählt ist und eben in der
mitte diese vertiefung hat kann man
schon dass das obst einfühlen und
daneben auch schön verzieren
ja so die obskuren gibt's ja auch fertig
zu kaufen diese böden aber ich finde das
lohnt sich gar nicht denn da muss man
weg fahren und eigentlich braucht man
einfach nur diese grundzutaten und hat
es auch ganz schnell selber gebunden und
die zeige ich euch noch kurz ich hab
hier 200 gramm zucker ich brauche eine
prise salz und nehmen etwas vanille
extrakt dann jeweils 75 gramm
mineralwasser und öl sonnenblumenöl aber
nicht gramm sondern milliliter dann habe
ich ihr 75 gramm mehl
hier habe ich 40 gramm speisestärke und
einen teelöffel backpulver das war schon
als im prinzip kann man den boden immer
machen wenn man mal rohstoffe hat und
deshalb grundzutaten die man eigentlich
immer eine speisekammer hat ich
zumindest
jetzt gehe ich erstmal die eier in die
schüssel er kommt als mit dazu mit dem
vanille extrakt ihr könnt auch hier
wieder wahrnehmen aber das schmeckt halt
besser und dann kommt auch direkt der
zucker mit rein und das wird jetzt schön
cremig verrührt
und wenn es dann schön schaumig verrührt
ist gebe ich noch die zwei flüssigkeiten
mit dazu öl und wasser also
mineralwasser ich habe halten sprudel
genommen
das wird ganz kurz ein gerührt
und die zeit nutze ich es auch schon mal
um eine backform einzubetten
dafür nehme ich meinen back trend muss
ich nicht aus pinseln aber wir können es
auch mit butter ausgehen sind es hier
schon rein pflanzlich und dann gemischt
es noch ein bisschen mit geht es später
leichter raus
dann kann ich hier bereits mehl
backpulver und stärkeren 7 so dass es
sich halt ein bisschen vermischt und so
gibt es halt auch keine klümpchen im
teig also deswegen sieht man dass frau
halt durch
und es wird auch ganz kurz bei niedriger
stufe 1 gehört
und dann könnt ihr den teig in die form
einfüllen
bis verteilen und dann wird er auch
schon im backofen vorgeheizt bei 175
grad ober und unterhitze so für ungefähr
15 minuten gebacken
ihm ist auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen kann auch sein dass er ein
paar minuten länger braucht aber nach 15
minuten schaue ich auf jeden fall schon
mal rein und dann hole ich ihn raus und
flossen komplett abkühlen fertig so
schnell geht es heute
mein ort kuchenteig ist es schön
abgekühlt und ich werde ihnen gleich mit
erdbeeren belegen und macht auch den
tortenguss selber und dafür brauche ich
einfach 250 milliliter saft da habe ich
jetzt ein erdbeersaft und weil der eben
schon gezuckert ich brauche ich keinen
zusätzlichen zucker dann habe ich hier
noch 30 gramm speisestärke ich bin jetzt
etwas saft stoppt damit der tortenboden
nicht so durchweicht und ich habe hier
fünf uhr kam etwa die habe ich bereits
gewaschen und entsteht
und jetzt gebe ich einfach den saft in
den kleinen trotz lassen ein bisschen
was übrig denn da kommt die stärkeren
und die berühre ich dann erstmal kurz
und lasst den saft einfach aufkochen
aber das warten noch ganz kurz weil ich
will erst die erdbeeren klein schneiden
nur kann ich hier schon mal die stärke
verrühren mit dem satz mit dem
radstreifen dann nehme ich mir die
erdbeeren
ohne euch lange überlegt wie ich sie
anrichten soll entweder können dass sie
so komplett drauf stellen und ihr könnt
sie entscheiden schneiden schreiben mag
ich nicht so besonders strand dann
schnell matschig werden
deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
die einfach zu halbieren und so wissel
unregelmäßig anzurichten
und deswegen halte ich jetzt einmal kurz
und jetzt transportiere ich meinen
kuchen auf meine servierplatten stützt
aber erst mal kurz darauf den abkühlt
gegner klebt manchmal an
ich wollte das jetzt einfach schnell
abkühlt ganz vorsichtig so besser ist
immer wenn ich es einfach auf ein
flaches geschirr tuch auf dem tisch
stürzt kann der teig nämlich auch schön
abkühlen
so geht's schneller weiter von ihnen
dann auch luft kriegt aber meist einfach
dann diesen deckel mit ab aber das ist
nicht schlimm
stört wir hier für mich hier noch drauf
panama city
da gebe ich ein bisschen saft stopp
drauf das verhindert einfach wirklich
dass dieser saft von den apple dann dem
trockenboden durchweicht es hat mir ganz
auf das lettern ganz durch lästig und
das mag ich nicht so gern
und dann könnte ich jetzt gleich die
erdbeer aus platzieren und darauf
anrichten
ohne in der zeit kann ich jetzt auch
hier schon mal den saft aufkochen
und wenn der saft dann kocht nehme ich
ihn einfach ganz kurz vom herr printer
und früher diese speisestärke saft
mischung mit ein
verrührt es schön und gibt es dann noch
mal auf dem herd und das ist einfach mal
kurz aufkochen
und dann gebt ihr einfach diesen
fertigen guss direkt auf die erdbeeren
drauf ich pinsel das jetzt erstmal so
wissel drüber dann kann ich nämlich
sicher gehen dass wirklich alle erdmann
bedeckt sind
man müsse man den kugeln noch abkühlen
lassen
dann gibt so richtig schöne geschlagene
schlagsahne mit dazu
murat wir können den kuchen anschneiden
erwischt und ich habe ihn jetzt aus dem
kühlschrank rausgenommen bin ich fan von
etwa kuchen muss einfach richtig schön
kalt sein der sich aus gekauft ich mich
auch gerade allen ernstes gefragt ob ich
den boden gekauft habe ich noch heute
stand deswegen als wirklichen fertige
boote kaufen freund sage ich noch dass
man denn der kauf muss er hat meine
mutter meine mutter ist raus naja also
wahrscheinlich nicht so viel zeit gehabt
wenn sie sechs kinder groß gezogen hat
meine älteren karrubis wobei deshalb
schneller geht selber gemacht mal wie
gut es aussieht hier ist noch etwas
stöckelt es kommt noch zu dir sonst lege
ich dir dass du drauf man kriegt es noch
ein schaden häubchen obendrauf
nebendran oben direkt oder weil die
immer beschwert ich würde eine torte man
richtig krieg schluss sogar noch im
münster richtig finde jetzt darf ich gar
nicht mal beschweren
da probiere und mir dann sagen wie das
schmeckt
blue stage wieder boden auch schmeckt ja
ich hab gar keinen boden abgegeben was
eher luftig locker es mal las leuten gut
findest dann richtig einfacher teig den
man halt immer schnell zubereiten kann
mit den grundzutaten dem man daheim hat
und ja ich richte sitzt noch ein bisserl
schön an hoffe dass ich noch ein schönes
foto hinkriegt und mir den einfach mal
nachmachen wollt geht eine frau verließ
- blog.de das steht noch einmal die
genauen mengenangaben und können dann
natürlich jedes andere auf stoff
benutzen
also ich nämlich erdbeeren weil wir
gerade besser so haben und ich das mit
erd- beim ganz gern mag aber man kann
auch bananen kiwis nehmer egal was also
hauptsache obst werden wenn bestimmt
auch ganz lecker aber so etwa ist mein
favorit den cortex kleinkrieg
sahnehäubchen drauf wir uns da sind ja
ich freue mich schon wieder aufs nächste
mal schaltet dann auch wieder ein und
wenn ihr gerne so mehr so einfache
rezepte haben wollt und schnelle rezepte
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
und ich mache das dann natürlich auch
immer ganz gern
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss